morning now to our series of dish we
call it around here a stroll into
history at one of the oldest pasta shops
in the country I like the music guys
like a big pizza pie yes
okay
I'm not gonna sing along
pops out tonight but I'll check it out
and all Tony goes okay all right I was
first opened it stores in 1906 and 117
years later the New York City
institution they are still thriving
supplies iconic restaurants like Tavern
on the Green El Molino and chips
products Nationwide now the fourth
generation of this restaurant is moving
into the future with personalized
private dinners I like that Nancy Chen
takes us inside the Italian food Mecca
Romana which comes from recipe in Rome
is actually like a porridge almost like
polenta stepping into the kitchen at
refero's is like taking a step back in
time when this starts to stiffen up you
got to really work it the recipes the
dishes even the equipment go back more
than a century and you literally just
turn it on WOW
ah what do you think about when you use
this to think that my great grandfather
was standing here touching the same
mechanisms
all the way back to 1920. that is just
so fascinating to me
the patriarch of the family Marcelo
rafetto opened the store in 1906 and in
1919 he bought the building where it
still stands today in 1972 Ramana
marcelo's daughter-in-law known as Nona
ran the business until she died in 2018.
what do you think that your grandfather
would say if he walked in and saw this
shop still running right now four
generations later
I would imagine you'd have tremendous
Pride that you know his genetic code
kept
driving in the same
way he made a living father-daughter Duo
Andrew and Sarah are the third and
fourth generations of rafettos
preserving Italian-American Tradition at
this pasta shop did you feel pressure to
get in the business I actually did not
at all I knew with conviction that this
was what I wanted to do not because I
was guilted or needed every day in store
they make 15 pots of sauces 10 pans of
their best-selling lasagna and dozens of
prepared meals and if you've eaten
Italian food in New York City well
chances are you've had their pasta they
Supply more than 300 restaurants
including some of the best known in the
city is this like the hidden secret to
good pasta in the city is that it
actually comes back to here it's from
here I would agree with that yeah
because so many people don't admit it
but it's from here they whipped up some
of their favorites for us like egg and
spinach fettuccine with the sun-dried
tomato pesto sauce this is really such a
special sauce that I want more people to
be aware of now I could eat this all day
their gnocchi is a Roman dish made
without potatoes cut into squares and
topped with rosemary oil and for dessert
a coffee list pistachio tiramisu
hmm
it's so light yet flavorful at the same
time did you learn something new about
Sarah now that you guys worked together
so closely I learned that she could
handle plenty and almost welcomes it
just a tough
ready to do it all you must be very
proud oh absolutely getting choked up
now Sarah is throwing open the doors to
referos in a new way after hours hello
hello everyone my name is Sarah refero
and you're at refero's fresh pasta
partnering with cook and food blogger
Emily fedner mash it up serve it with
olive oil and onions it's like a Russian
baba ganoush she's launched a popular
monthly dinner series calling it petite
pasta joint Petit pasta joint is Sarah
and I's love child it's a representation
of our friendship it's a representation
of her Nana my Bob wish God it's a
representation of History
they shop for farm fresh ingredients
and prepare the seven course meal
themselves this dinner that we're having
tonight sold out in three minutes after
we release tickets bringing together two
dozen diners for cozy family style meal
really interactive we explain every
course and it is a special experience
with food that means something to us
that is unique
the menu often changes with one
exception their signature ditch raviolo
Al wovo an egg yolk filled pasta top
with a brown miso butter sauce do you
feel like you're taking your family's
store into the next chapter with this
with my own Flair because it's all of
our responsibilities as the new
generation to contribute something so
that makes me feel very special and very
proud that I'm able to bring this to the
family
[Music]
okay Sarah and Emily my kind of girls I
love Sarah's dad choking up when he
started talking about his daughter when
he says she can handle everything I have
great appreciation for family businesses
especially when it's got your name like
the decouples yes I think that's so cool
when the generations continue in the
future and the fact that they
acknowledge that yeah her grandfather
would have sat yes in that same machine
um I think it's very powerful yeah it's
a gorgeous thing